one biggest thing going back to the
house one biggest thing that i've had to
go to get used to uh living in the house
is uh living on the ground floor now
right oh yeah i've
only lived i've only lived in japan i
mean it's like i've only lived in
apartments in japan before and i was
like quite high up in my old apartment
so you know what you know i could stand
next to the window and uh be pretty
confident that no one was going to see
me you know you know yeah
you know
especially you know
when you sleep you sometimes you just
sleep in boxes as a as
as you do and sometimes sometimes you're
just out of the shower and you don't get
dressed
exactly you don't get dressed straight
away you put on your boxes or whatever
you just walk around the apartment um
and uh i i kind of realized that you
can't do that in houses
so our house has like pretty big [ __ ]
windows right yeah and so i have a
shower put on my boxes and uh
so
the bathroom uh or my shower room and my
wardrobe is on different floors right so
finishing shower go up to the go up to
my living room and just you know
chilling you know before i put on some
clothes um go up to go up to my window
to like admire the view
as you do sometimes just admire the
sunshine on the ground floor admire the
pavement
on on the first floor on the first wow
it's a little elevation a little bit
across one meter actually yeah so it
changes everything yeah because you know
so sometimes when i was on when i was on
the when i was on like the eighth floor
back my own apartment sometimes you just
like to look down breathe in the
sunshine and i thought i'd do the same
routine uh so i was just standing in my
window um and then
uh someone opens their uh
someone goes out to the balcony to put
out some clothes
and uh me and them need eye contact and
um i i'm totally not used to this
because back in when you're in an
apartment i was used to just being by
the window and nobody could see you
because you're too high up to be seen
yeah um and then so we make eye contact
and then they immediately just
close the closed sliding door again and
then i realize i'm just standing next to
my window with my boxes out and people
can very visibly see me and i'm like 20
meters away it was this person they were
like across the road so 10 meters away
yeah it's like 10 meters away so they
had 4k definitions
literally caught in 4k my god if it was
mailing she would like be
she would have seen my nipples and
everything [ __ ] scarred for life
there my god fallen right off the
balcony i'm not
in shock
are you liking a new place though so far
yeah yeah yeah i'm really liking it
also another thing uh
i had to go back to my house by myself
to pick up some stuff pretty late at
night and uh
it's uh it's it's pretty scary to go
back it's it's creepy as [ __ ] to go in
the house and i didn't i didn't realize
that until i went in
because when you're in apartment there
are like lights
like outside of your building yeah right
there there are lights and there are
people living next to you yeah you go in
this house um and it's just pitch black
and you're just by yourself and you're
like you know what i wasn't afraid of
the dark until i experienced this and
i'm so creepy about an empty apartment
pitch black there was something really
weird about it yeah an apartment's like
i can handle an apartment because the
worst thing if you if something happens
if like a [ __ ] murderer is there or a
[ __ ] burglar is there you can scream
and people are people around you yeah
you have too much confidence in people
yeah i think i think i think you like
your neighbors a little too much
i don't know maybe it's probably just
like a placebo but
murderers in japan i'm sure i'm their
apartment yeah i know but i don't know
maybe it's a placebo but it feels safer
it just feels
it i don't know it's like having a night
light you know it feels like it feels
like it's not too far away from your
front door whereas in the house you're
kind of just there by yourself and uh it
we we have a detached house as well so
um so it feels like you're just
completely there
isolated whereas in an apartment
you know there there's the apartment
block where there's people outside
sometimes going in and out there's
lights even at night time um so just i
don't know right it just it just feels
like you're a bit more isolated it feels
scarier uh i could see why people get
scared of ghosts now in japan
[Laughter]
because it's [ __ ] creepy as [ __ ] oh
yeah yeah definitely